hello this is Matthew from simply learn
and today we're gonna go through a
complete end-to-end journey on what it
takes to set up a dev ops team we're
gonna go through what we need to be able
to do to go to dev ops what the
arguments are on why you need to do dev
ops and they will actually go through
with all the individual tools you need
to be able to successfully implement dev
ops within your organization in addition
to that we're also going to take time
and go through each of those tools so
you get a good understanding of a
step-by-step instructions on how to do
basic setup of each of those tools so
let's get started so what was dev ops
before so what was the process that we
took were doing delivery before dev ops
well it was a model called waterfall and
waterfall was a very traditional
approach to actually building out
solutions and the reason why it's called
waterfall is that you bring out all the
individual requirements and individual
sections of a project and they cascade
off each other
so if we look at the breakdown we have
requirements design we have
implementation we have verification we
have maintenance you'll have user
acceptance testing and this is all based
on the software development lifecycle
model SDLC and it's been around for
quite some time and it's still used by a
lot of companies today the challenge
you've had with the waterfall model is
that it really is a very long drawn out
model for actually building and
delivering solutions so it took a very
long time to actually write code and
then deploy the code it was very
difficult to actually identify problems
within the code and provide feedback to
the development team on what to fix and
this really was a very time-consuming
we're talking about months sometimes
years for projects to be actually go
through a waterfall model process so
along came a new method of being able to
do delivery and it's called agile and
the agile approach is a way of being
able to take the actual work that's done
in a waterfall model and compress it
down into small iterations and what we
would do is a fundamental changes that
you would actually take a team
that were disparate and as part of the
individual cascades within a waterful
project and as you bring them together
so you have your requirements team and
person design developer and release
management team all together in one
group working on an iteration the great
thing about agile is that you took a
process that was weeks um or months or
even years in length as it was with
waterfall and you reduce it down to two
or four week Sprint's by depending on
the cadence for your team typically you
have a two week spring and then the goal
is is that at the end of each sprint or
sometimes every other sprint you would
do a software release and so that
customers were getting the software much
faster the problem that we still ran
into though with agile is fundamentally
similar to what we were having with
waterfall you have your DevOps person
working on code on their system and
you'd be working great on their computer
and then you have the operations person
who's migrating the code from the
developers environment the test
environment - for the production
environment and you would run into
issues where the code simply wasn't
working there's a lot of reasons why
that would happen the actual developer
environment would often be very
different or would have different
dependencies in it so the the hardware
that the software there may be
additional applications that were
installed on the operating system that
simply hadn't been transferred over to
the operations environment and so what
you would have is a disconnect between
the developer environment and the
operations environment making it
difficult and try to roll out codes
you'd run into a program where that when
you rolled out code you'd have to have a
rollback plan in case the code wouldn't
work in production and so each release
became a vent wherever I got very
stressed about the actual event of
releasing code because you didn't know
whether it was going to work so dev amps
really looks to address and solve a lot
of these problems so the key word that
you'll often hear with DevOps is
continuous integration and what that
means is essentially that as it dove
is working on their coat the coat is
constantly being tested against not just
the actual code itself with unit testing
but the environment with which it's
going to be released in and the goal
from a DevOps model is that the
breakdown of communication that happens
with waterfall and agile with dev
developers and operations teams aren't
working in the same brand is being
removed and you're able to provide a
continuous and contiguous environment
between the developer and the apple
actual operating model so the reality is
when the developer is working on their
code they're actually working in an
environment that is identical to the
production environment and so when the
actual operations person comes try to do
releases for the code and you can see
some teams are doing as many as 22 even
up to 50 releases to production
environments every single day you're
able to guarantee that the actual code
itself will work and releases go from
being a stressful event to a byproduct
of good testing and good setup and
structure for how you actually build out
your solutions so what we're seeing here
so the goal is that as a developer and
as an Operations person that the code is
working continuously in both
environments you have continuous
integration and continuous delivery so
simply put what we're able to do is
we're able to eliminate the problem of
the operation environment not being in
sync with the development environment
and this is a improvement on edge on
this is not to say that waterfall or
agile are wrong as delivery models what
it is is just a maturity of the ability
to deliver solutions and DevOps is just
another rung in that maturity curve
using tools that are available to us now
that 5 10 years ago simply weren't
available so the goal is for you as a
team to move to a dev ops model where
you can implement continuous releases on
your software as long as you're using
the tools that are available and the
good news is those tools are open source
tools so let's go through
some of the benefits of why you'd want
to go and use DevOps so you know
essentially what's in it for you so
let's over the next few slides we're
gonna go through what is DevOps we're
gonna go through the benefits of DevOps
so in the last few slides you've
actually seen you know what is DevOps
and the benefits of DevOps along with
the lifecycle but we're also going to
start digging into the tools that you
have that are useful for DevOps
and we're going to focus in on seven
tools that can provide an end-to-end
infrastructure for delivering DevOps
solutions with there are significantly
more tools available on the market but
these are seven of the most popular for
each of their categories so DevOps
really is an essential collaboration
between the development team and the
operations team these are teams that
have in past been somewhat at conflict
with each other and what you have now is
an opportunity where those teams can can
now work continuously with each other
the expectation with DevOps is that it
will continue to mature indeed you're
actually even seeing some groups which
are now called dev sac ops where they're
integrating security as part of the
delivery between the development team
and the operations team the bottom line
is a DevOps engineer is highly in demand
the demand for DevOps engineer is
literally going through the roof with
salaries going ups exponentially around
that so let's dig into some of the
benefits of DevOps it's not just a new
catchphrase it's actually got
significant value and how you can speed
up delivery of your software so the
benefits of DevOps can really broken up
into a number of key areas first of all
we have continuous delivery of software
which allows you to continuously release
new features with the security and
understanding that the software going
out is of high quality it allows the
teams that are working on the software
delivery within your organization to
more effectively collaborate with each
other so that you're all talking from
the same page and understanding of what
needs to be delivered the deployment
process itself moves from being an event
where there's a lot of stress and
there's a lot of contingency plans to
being a much easier deployment the
efficiency within the actual code that
you're writing the ability to scale up
using the different tools are available
allows you to be able to bring in and
scale up and reduce the teams you have
running the software as needed errors
can be fixed much earlier and more
quickly and can be caught before
anything gets pushed out to the
production environment and fundamentally
what we're looking for is improving the
security of the actual releases so the
actual concept of security is Center to
all the work you're doing and then
finally what really allows you to reduce
the number of errors is that there is
much less manual intervention there is a
greater reliance on scripted
environments that you can actually test
and validate for their security
reliability and uptime efficiency so
let's talk a little bit about the life
cycle of a DevOps so the very first step
that you're take is to actually build
out a build and test environment and
this is a continuous building testing
brand and this is merge away the first
step of your source code once you move
through that and you're looking at
continuous integration which means that
every time somebody checks in their code
they're validating that the code
actually can run in the production
environment once you've actually been
passed the end continuous integration
and the testing that you have with your
code you're looking at continuous
deployment if the code works and is
available to be released into the
production environment let's go ahead
and release it and once you actually
have release code then you want to be
able to validate that your environment
is working efficiently you may release
code that is a new feature within your
application and customers may then graft
it immediately to that new feature if
they do you want to be able to ensure
that the code is working and more
importantly but the infrastructure is
there to support and then finally you're
looking at software released as a
continuous event and then you go back to
the beginning you start working on more
code you run it through your build
environment and continuous integration
deployment continuous monitoring and
keep that cycle
moving so let's dig into the tools that
you as a DevOps engineer would need to
learn if we break down the environment
that we have all the way from source
code management to software release and
there are a number of key tools that you
want to be able to use so for instance
source code management can get is an
open source tool that you would want to
used from managing your code the
continuous build and test environment
will be managed with mavin and selenium
integration with the environments that
you're working on is managed through
jenkins the actual deployment to your
production environment will be managed
with products such as ansible and docker
and then the monitoring of your network
would be used with tools like Nettie O's
the thing that you have to remember with
all these tools is that they're
open-source tools there is no licensing
that you have to you a purchase some of
the tools will have a pro level
licensing that you can choose to select
but to get started
all of these are open source tools you
can actually start using for free right
now so let's dig in to get so let's look
at the the challenge that git is able to
address so before git and you if you had
a team of developers that were working
on different pieces of code one the key
problems you have is that there was no
collaboration between the team and the
the challenge you have is that with
version control it was difficult and
often required I'm having to check in
two large environments or you had very
you know quasi version control
environments it was time consuming
often there were problems that were
would happen if this the version control
server would crash and there wasn't a
backup then you'd have to kind of
essentially go back to square zero to
see whether or not you actually had to
do the work again so let's look at what
git does to actually solve this so first
of all one of the things that it does is
it makes team collaboration much easier
the software itself is more effectively
documented and more and more effectively
maintained the actual code that actually
gets worked on by each developer in a
gate environment is the complete code so
it makes it much easier for backups and
for sharing content amongst each and
so the way in which get is able to
accomplish this is that it is
essentially a distributed version
control solution and what that means is
that when you have multiple developers
yes you do have a git remote hub that
you connect and are able to upload and
download different branches of the code
that you're working on but essentially
as a developer when you actually have
the code you actually have all of the
code and you're able to imagine firm
your local PC or your local development
machine and without having to worry too
much about the network or the server
going down so some of the key things in
which get is really good at it is you
know a software management tool is
designed from the ground up to merge
code development it does track the
changes on that code easily and
effectively makes it easy for use
developer to track your code the ability
for multiple developers to work together
is much easier in comparison to other
solutions and and this is really the the
key success point with a kit is that it
allows for nonlinear code development so
you can actually have people working on
different areas of the code that may be
released at different times because of
what they're working on so if we
actually break down the architecture of
get it really calls into four key areas
of a working directory a local staging
area a local repository and a remote
repository so the process you'll go
through is you would add files to the
staging area from your working directory
this would be usually they get add
command and then from your staging area
when you're ready to actually then
commit those files to a local repository
you use the git commit command and then
from there you would actually then push
your local repository out to the remote
repository for a final commit to the
remote repository and this allows them
the rest of the team to pull down your
latest final changes so you can be
working on your code locally and you can
be using your local eat local staging
area and local repository and when
you're ready to commit your work
committed and Anna Souza's committed the
rest of the teams and then pulled out
the latest changes that you have worked
on and this allows for a complete and
holistic check out round check-in
process and then sometimes you want to
be able to go through and then take the
checked out code that you cram that
you're pulling out and merge it with
your local code and the merge process
always ensure that you are working on
the latest and best version of the code
and everybody on the team is being
consistent with the communication of the
actual code that's being delivered okay
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
validate that we have get running on a
computer we're gonna vent create a
directory and a file to that directory
make some changes to that file and then
use the commit commands to be able to
check in the files and validate to
ensure being made so first thing we do
is we're gonna see if we have git
installed and still have do you just use
the command git version and what you'll
get - - version I'm not even give you
the version number and now we're gonna
create a new folder so m'kay dirt green
and they'll create a new folder and
we'll move our cursor into the green
folder by changing the directory and we
can go back into Windows and we can
validate that that directory is actually
there so here we go
look we should see if there's the green
folder if I double click into that
you'll see there's nothing in the folder
right now so what we have to do is we
actually have to add the folder as part
of a git project and so we're going to
use our get in the [ __ ] in it and
they'll actually initialize the folder
and make it a git repository and so
let's go ahead and create a file though
actually go inside of that new
initialized folder and you'll see that
there's a dot git folder that's been
added so the new text file we're gonna
create it's gonna be code class and
they'll let you be class dot txt the
extension is hidden by default in the
text file we're just gonna type in the
text welcome to simply learn and save
that now let's go ahead and check the
status on all of that file in gate so to
do git status and you'll see that it
says yes there's a file there but it
hasn't been committed to the repository
that's why it's in red
so we have to do is commit the file to
the repository and it won't be able to
track any changes that we do to that
file so let's go ahead and commit the
file so we do commit and class txt and
they'll add back to the repository and
there we are it's added and the final
step is we want to do is commit it and
to get so it's to get commit - and like
and this will be our first commit and
this is the description and so it she
shows us committing the file it's the
only item in the folder so now we can go
over to the file that we just created
and we can make some changes to it so
open up the file so it says welcome to
simply learn let's put in some text
afterwards that says this is my demo and
we'll save that close that and now if we
go back to get we can do a compare and
contrast between the original file that
we committed and the new updates that
we've just done and we can check the
difference by using git diff and what
you'll see is the red text was the
original text and the green text is now
the new text that's been added and so
that shows you how you can she go and
create a new git repository go through
adding files committing the files into
the repository and being able to see the
different version controls let's move on
to mavin so when I use mavin so so why
use married well this look at some of
the things that you were done in the
past have you actually building out the
tasks so let's break down what you would
have done before using mavin if you were
to create a game or football using Java
you would actually have to go out and
for your actual game you'd have to
collect all the different components
needed within the Java environment and
to make sure that everything would work
correctly and if you make the slightest
mistake you wouldn't get the right
output that you needed the actual
process of building and deploying a
project really would take quite a lot of
time after mavin mavin allows you to be
able to take templates that are stored
locally and be able to use those to be
able to improve the efficiency of being
able to build out your environment by
removing dependencies within the
application it makes it a lot easier
if you'd be able to focus on just
writing the code for your game or your
solution rather than having to manage
the environment within which that
solution would be deployed now the focus
within mavin is that it is an automation
tool and it's used for projects to have
a short period of time so as you're
starting on your environment for
building out solutions mavin is great to
get started with and then if you need to
have longer-term projects then you can
look at other alternative tools on the
market so four key areas that you want
to focus on why mavin can help you is
that it does allow for efficient some
parallel builds to be run concurrently
it's really easy to use you can get up
and started with math very quickly you
do have fast access to new features and
new configurations quickly within your
environment and the build process that
will allow you to be able to visualize
your code happens very quickly the
actual architecture of mavin is that the
execution and commands are managed
through what's known as a pom file the
pom file itself is a project object
model and it's an XML file that actually
has the details for the project and the
configuration for the build environment
on file itself will then fetch
dependencies from the local repository
and will apply any plugins that you may
have also included within your mapping
environment the goal is that your
software is build much more controlled
at Manor so what we can do now is we're
going to show you how to go through and
run your very first project using maven
the first steps you can have to do is
make sure that you have the latest JDK
installed on your computer so we're
gonna go ahead and open up our web
browser and get this installed on your
computer so we're going to type in JDK
download into our Chrome web browser and
go to the oracle website which allows us
to learn download the JDK because we're
running this on Windows we're going to
download the Windows version of the JDK
and once you have that installed
the next step is to actually then go
ahead and download the Maven files so
it's going to take us to the Maven
apache
org website where you can go ahead and
download the version of maven that you
need for your operating system we're
going to go ahead and download the zip
file instead of just an executable file
now this will give you more control over
how you install it onto your Windows PC
after the file has been downloaded we
want to go ahead and extract the entire
file so you have the unzipped folder
running on your computer
so one of the things that we're gonna
have to do is go through and set a
number of system variables for the JDK
infinite path to your mavim files and to
do that you want to go into your control
panel and select the system security and
then system settings and then go into
advanced system settings this will give
you access to the Edit system variable
setting that you're looking for
so we're gonna go down to the path
variable and you'll see already that we
have pasted in the link to the JDK right
there underneath the variable value if
you've been stole the JDK it's likely
that's already installed this path for
you correctly
the good news it's actually fairly easy
to install the path to man and to the
JDK because all you have to do is copy
the path for where the folder is located
on your system and just paste it into
the variable value under the Edit
Systems variable fault and file system
and that should now get us all the files
and you can see that we have our
extracted folder already on our desktop
there and the system path is now set to
where the moment folder is located so we
also have to go into system protection
and
[Music]
set the system off - ummm folder now we
have to go ahead and do a user variable
that also part links to the path of
mavin files
so what we're doing right now is we're
just validating that all the files have
been extracted correctly they have which
is good we can now go ahead and link to
these moment folder all right so now
what we do is we're going to move over
to command prompt this is where we're
going to do most of our work from here
on out first come on we're going to do
is MV so we go ahead and create a new
user variable and we're going to type in
we're gonna cause one enter - and then
we'll put in the path to the apache
moment folder you should be able to use
m2 - home for your price but if it's not
you can always use the verbal name map
and - home and that will do exactly the
same as empty I'm going to both here
just so we have a backup
so we're gonna open up command prompt
and we're going to see if Maybin is in
store we do that by writing MVN - -
version and here we are yes so now we're
going to go ahead and create our first
maven project and the first part of
creating maven project is actually the
directory in which we will store the
files that will be used to create for
our project so we're just going to go
ahead into the folder and we're gonna
create new directory and we're going to
call this one and we're gonna call it
simply learn and we can just copy the
path for them so I'm gonna write this
the correct path for it so I'm gonna
change directory CD and you copy the
file location over alright we are now
moved ourselves over to the simply
learned folder and we'll be able to
install the pom file which is what all
the instructions for mavin are stored in
into this area so to do that we're
actually going to use a template that's
already been created by mavin and this
is going to be the MVN archetype
template and so you just - mbm :
generate and this will go ahead and
create all the files for us
so this can be quite a few files and
they're all being downloaded from the
event website and so it can take some
time but as you see we've gone ahead and
all the files have downloaded and we
have everything up and running correctly
inside of our environment on online and
come on prompt so we'll have some values
that we do have to say it
the first one is group ID and we're
going to call this one comm math and
then the next one is going to be
artifact ID and this is going to be MAV
ma v - project hit return and then
version is going to be 1.0 - snapshot
which is put in the same value for this
version 1.0 - snapshot and the package
we're going to take call this one comb
math dot demo and then we'll select yes
so wife to create the environment and it
will build the environment for us and
what we have now so we have this screen
which shows everything is up and running
for us and we have a successful build
and so let's go into the main folder and
just see that we have our simply lim
folder let's open up and see what's in
there so we double click into that
directory yep and there we are sty and
see some of our files so it's the same
project names as ma v - project and then
we have our pom file that's in there
which is fantastic under the source
folder we'll actually see the demo and
we have our app under the demo app
we have our test file as well so in the
main folder we have a file that's called
the pom file and that really is the most
important file that you need for your
project you'll now go and you'd be able
to set all your settings inside of that
pom file but that's it that's what we
have done here is we've gone through and
we've gone through all the setup that
allows you to make sure you have the
right files running on your computer the
right files to download from the Maven
website how to install all the files the
settings you need to make on your
Windows computer and then all the
settings that need to be done in the
command line to be able to run the
application and then from here you can
actually start running maven now let's
look at selenium as we get started
looking at testing so before selenium if
you want to run testing and particularly
you want to do sequential testing it
would take up a lot of time you'd have
to run one test then the second test and
then all the other tests and the actual
time elapsed would be quite significant
with Selim you're actually able to do
parallel testing so instead of looking
at the amount of time you take to
achieve run a test and run the tests
sequentially the length of time to
actually run your tests is based on the
length of the longest running test of
which in this example the longest
running test is two minutes now one of
the things that you'll notice with
selenium is that its focus is on web
applications and it is an open source
tool and it's really good at regression
and functional testing of web
applications if you're doing a mobile
application or if you're doing an IOT
application there are other tools you
can use on the market as well but if you
are new to DevOps and you're setting up
your first DevOps environment selenium
is a great place to start and web
applications are mature and allow you to
be able to test out and validate the
concept of continuous testing in your
environment so four key takeaways for
selenium it really is fast and it's fast
execution it's highly accurate so you
can always validate that what you're
doing will work correctly and feedback
can be sent straight back to the
but if their code doesn't pass the test
allows you to script in the multiple
languages again it's a great way for you
to test and the focus is on web
applications but you can test in
multiple languages useful web
applications and most importantly allows
for parallel test execution which speeds
up the whole test process significantly
I want you to break down the
architecture of selenium and what you'll
find is the actual libraries that you
can use for selenium run in c-sharp Java
Python JavaScript PHP these are the
common languages used to build out web
applications the actual webdriver itself
is an API driver which is fantastic
because it makes it easier for you to
integrate selenium with applications
through API and you can run the solution
through different web browsers the most
popular being firefox chrome and edge so
to focus the selenium webdriver codes
are being used to build out the client
libraries that make it LOM to allow you
to be able to build solutions across
multiple web application environments
the webdriver application interface is
you to integrate with the application to
make it easy for testing the webdriver
service provides an immutable stateless
environment that makes it very easy for
you to be able to use protocol such as
JSON to wire up your test environment
the driver manages the communication
between the browsers and the wire
protocol that's used for JSON within the
web browser itself and then the actual
commands are then run through the web
browser for you to be able to get your
results okay so before we had to get
into the setup of so any of the first
things we want to do is we want to make
sure that we have the right version of
Java installed and so I'm just using
command window here I'm going to type in
Java and she what it see now is I do
have Java installed which is fantastic
Oh as you'd have to go and download Java
from Oracle's website the next step is
to validate by have Eclipse installed
and I'm just typing Eclipse and there we
are I have the clips installed you can
actually download eclipse from the
eclipse website the third step I want to
check is to validate that I
a browser driver installed so I'm using
Google's Chrome and for my main browser
but you can actually go out and download
the chromium driver and that's the
actual core engine that powers Chrome
interesting enough being used in the new
Microsoft edge web browser so you get to
go and download the latest chromium
driver and install that and then the
final stage is to go to the selenium web
site and download the jar files
themselves so just do a google search on
selenium download and here we have the
selenium hq2 org website when you take
straight to a download page and we want
to download the latest version and we've
gone ahead and done that already so we
have everything running and now the next
step is for us to install all of this
great content okay so before we had to
get into the setup of so any of the
first things we want to do is we want to
make sure that we have the right version
of driver install and so I'm just using
command window here I'm going to type in
Java and she what I see now is I do have
Java installed which is fantastic oh as
you'd have to go and download Java from
Oracle's website the next step is to
validate I have Eclipse installed and
I'm just typing Eclipse and there we are
I have the clips and so you can actually
download eclipse from the Eclipse
website the third step I want to check
is to validate that I have a browser
driver installed so I'm using Google's
Chrome for my main browser but you can
actually go out and download the
chromium driver and that's the actual
core engine that powers Chrome
interesting enough being used in the new
Microsoft edge web browser so you get to
go and download the latest chromium
driver and install that and then the
final stage is to go to the selenium web
site and download the jar files
themselves so just do a google search on
selenium download and here we have the
selenium hq2 org website and you take
straight to the download page and we
want to download the latest version and
we've gone ahead and done that already
so we have everything running and now
the next step is for us to install
all of this great content so we're just
going to go ahead and open up the
Eclipse environment and it takes a
moment to launch eclipse
I'm going to go ahead and create a new
project and we're going to call our
project XYZ I think that should be fine
and this is just a test after all and
we're gonna go ahead and create a new
class file by right-clicking and select
new class and we're gonna go in here and
give the class file a name of simply
learn and let's see the finish button
being selected so maybe we need to
select some other options here oh you
know I think it could be the package
name yeah let me go ahead and change the
package name and I'm going to change
that to qwe qwf yep and the finish
button has now been highlighted I can
select that I can go select that let's
like finish and we now have a test page
as up and running and but what we have
to do is validate that selenium is
actually part of the project so to do
that when you go to the source to the
actual sauce XYZ file and right click on
it and we want to validate that all the
files are there correctly and so going
to see that we have the libraries are
there yep there's selenium if it's not
there you can say add external files and
find the selenium jar file sect open and
they'll would load that in there and
then you hit apply in close and they
would apply it to your project and now
we can actually start writing the code
part so we're gonna put this code in the
public static void section and the first
command is going to be a system dot set
property and we want to make sure that
we're configuring the webdriver for
chromium correctly so we're gonna do
webdriver and chrome driver and then the
argument is actually going to be the
full path full network path to the
chromium driver that you have on your PC
so let's see we have chrome here we want
to copy that path and so I paste that in
and then after we
paste it in the path we have to make
sure that we also put a link to the
actual file that we want to execute
which in this case is chrome driver
Exe
and then we want to make sure that the
web driver is pointing to the new Chrome
driver
and you'll notice that there's a couple
of red colors on here which means that
we don't have all of the public classes
imported correctly so you can write
clear commitments like import the
webdriver and just select that real
quick and that adds the import correctly
at the top of the page and same for
chrome driver and that's just a very
quick way and when you're working
Eclipse to import additional files so
before we actually start our test we
want to make sure that we've actually
cleared out any potential browser
cookies that would be within the
criminal driver so for that we're just
going to go ahead and we're going to
write a script that allows us to remove
the cookies
so I want to drive a duck marriage and
then delete all cookies
and the next line we're going to do is
to actually have the webpage that we're
going to connect to open up in
full-screen mode and for that to happen
we're going to go and actually use the
window property which wishes what I was
writing before by mistake and so this
will allow us to go fullscreen and now
we need to pull in a web page so we're
gonna get the get command and what we're
going to do is we're actually just gonna
pull in a web page from Amazon I would
trade you something to have here so I'm
just going to go to amazon web page and
so I'm just gonna copy the URL and you
know just need to copy HTTP wwm
seungyeon or calm wherever you're
located and so you can see that I've
pulled in the Amazon Web page and then
line 18 and she allows me to go and
connect so here we are we have the
Amazon Web page so I'm pulling in and
then what I also want to do is I want to
look for a specific ID in one of the
elements and so I have the driver which
is called fide and element and that
allows me to look for any element that
beyond the actual page so here we have
the HTML in the console screen and I can
actually then paste out an ID from the
element that I want to use
so the find element is just the ID for
each element and most of them have them
because they needed for the JavaScript
and CSS so let's see there's quite a few
IDs and we can select any of those so
what we have here is we have two tab
search text box and then what that
actually does is that finds the ID for
the text box used for searching and then
we're gonna use the st. key command
which allows us to actually pre fill in
the search box and we're going to use
the test of puma shoes this is a fixed
string but you can actually put a
variable in here if you want to pull
strings from a database or an XML file
and then the next line on line 19 which
shows how long actually gonna run the
actual script for the search which is
only 10 seconds and then once the 10
seconds has elapsed we'll actually quit
this script which actually causes the
web browser and takes us back into a
screen hint let's test that make sure
it's working and everything's looking
good the web browser opens which is what
we expect it goes to Amazon fantastic
right now and she goes to the search
screen and should fill in the Puma shoes
there we get puma shoes and wait 10
seconds and it closes and that's exactly
what we were expecting now you can
actually change the unit of time that
you would have for the actual test so if
you wanted to see what was happening so
longer than 10 seconds you can actually
change the actual time or the actual
metric and so in this instance we got it
says seconds and see unit of time or you
could do minutes or hours or
microseconds and you can change the
keyword as well so it could be jigsaws
or anything you want to check but if
you're actually building your own
application you want to be able to test
your own data against your own
application that's where you put in that
specific data
so let's look at the center the heart of
your DevOps environment and that Center
is with Jenkins
so before Jenkins people would
developers would work on their code and
the code would then be checked into a
source repository you would then check
for any issues and then you would then
send that code over to the operations
team and there would be a delay for
actually delivering software so the item
challenges developers hand is that if
they wanted to run any tests they had to
wait until their software was built and
there was a lot of problems in providing
feedback and particularly had large
teams working on software who actually
had the error the actual delivery of
software was often delayed because of
these key problems
so after Jenkins what we actually have
is the ability to be able to streamline
this whole process the build test and
deploy happens continuously and are able
to then notify developers and the actual
specific developer of any errors that
are detected being able to speed up the
delivery process much more efficiently
the focus of Jenkins is that it
automates a continuous development
testing and deployment environment and
it's open source
Jenkins is easy to install and configure
it's been around for many years now and
it is very mature
there are many plugins that you can use
within Jenkins to be able to have the
Jenkins product work with your
environment if there isn't a plug-in you
can actually extend by you can actually
write your own plugins if a plug-in
doesn't exist so you can actually
continue and extend and invest in the
Jenkins ecosystem and it can be easily
distributed across multiple machines so
let's break out the architecture of
Jenkins so checking such as a remote
source code repository and it then pulls
out the code every time there is a
commit from and into the server master
the server that master will then have a
slave that will run on either Windows
Linux or Mac OS to be able to just we
just load across those environments and
after it's actually gone
true and run his tests ill then send out
a report the goal of a report is to
communicate back to the team what has
passed and what has failed the actual
check-in process okay so we're gonna go
ahead and show you how to install
Jenkins on your local PC so the first
thing you want to do is check that you
have Java installed so we're just gonna
go into our system and see whether or
not we have the Java JDK installed you
ended up by going into system properties
secondly advanced and environment
settings and there we have Java JDK
installed and you want to just double
check on the system variables to make
sure that you have the Java and score
home installed correctly as well and we
have that consult and under path also
make sure you have a link to the Java
JDK as well so we have everything
installed and what we're going to do is
we're gonna open up the command window
and just do a door check right there
so about command window and we're just
going to check that we have Gerrans sort
so we do Java - version and we have a
version number comes back if we do have
Java installed we'll and get a Java
version number come back with a a Venera
all right so everything that's good so
next thing you want to do is to go to
the Jenkins website and download the
files so we're gonna go to Jenkins dot
IO and that's the official drinkin's
website and if you want to download you
just go to Jenkins io / download or you
can just type into your search bar
download Jenkins and they'll give you a
link straight to the download page and
one of things that you'll see is that
there's lots of different versions for
Jenkins because Jenkins runs on pretty
much most operating systems including
Windows Linux and Mac OS but we want to
select the Windows version so we've
already gone ahead and downloaded zip
file which contains all of the files
that we need for Jenkins and so that's
the zip file and we've expanded it and
what we want to do now is double click
the installer file and we'll go ahead
and install that
so we've already installed this so one
things that we'll get is a message to
ASCII we want to repair you did she get
a install message because it would be a
fresh install for you and but once
you've done that has all the files and
all
two things correctly installed onto your
Windows computer and we do all my
commands for Jenkins through a web page
that's run locally on your PC and so
you're gonna type in localhost colon
8080 and when you do that they'll
actually take you to Jenkins running
locally on your PC and here we have our
Jenkins dashboard and we've already gone
in and created some sample jobs and you
can see those listed on the throwing on
the right-hand side of the screen so
let's go through some of the things you
would want to set up here so first of
all let's go into the manage Jenkins
screen and that will achieve so we'll go
to the manage Jenkins tab on the left
hand side to do some standard
configuration settings so we're going to
the configuration systems and if you
want to if you're like remotely
connecting to a remote Jenkins
environment you can actually install a
JDK remotely but on that machine if you
want to now we already have the JDK
environment already set up so yeah
that's good here it's going to do that
but you also see as you go through the
list of applications that you have
Gradle ant mavin docker
get and other tools that you would use
in DevOps environments there are many
other tools you can install through
plugins as well let's have a look at one
more setting here with the security the
default security is Jenkins own user
database that probably is not allowed
within your company due to security
restrictions and so you can choose LDAP
which allows you to connect with your
Active Directory configuration again
because there are so many plugins for
Jenkins there are plugins for sam'l
authentication as well as auth
so let's go ahead and start a new build
new build job and so it's like a new
item and we to select demo one from that
create a new item and we're going to use
just a freestyle project because I just
want to demo how you can actually create
a bill it's like okay description oh
gosh what can we write here we can put
in Snoopy demo and we're not gonna use
source code for this one we can do that
in the next demo but let's go we want to
go down to is the
uptime and we're going to build and we
can just two and four win excuse me this
magic wand and so let's just put in a
very simple command and so I'm going to
type in echo open quotes hello world and
then we'll put in the timestamp so put
in date first and then time as part of
our output those quotes and we're gonna
say that also save and that's our simple
projects so we want to do now is we want
to actually go and select the build now
command to actually run this project
built now take a couple of minutes for
it to run and here we are this is our
project and go geez now see the
different builds that have happened and
if you look on the build history you'll
see the latest history shows when the
build was executed and if you click on
that you can actually start getting
information such as the console output
what she provide information that we
were asking for so for instance we have
its first so we can see that the build
was successful and we see the output
includes the hello all and date and time
so we're gonna go ahead and create one
more project where we can actually
connect to a github and use the git
command tool to be able to build a real
project so we're gonna go ahead and
create a new item and we're gonna call
this one
Jenkins it's freestyle project and our
description is demo using git and so
we're actually going to connect to
github and so to do that we're gonna go
in to source code management tab and we
can stay get and so we select that we
can actually now connect to github so to
do that you go to your github account
and you want to go in and select the
clone or download and you get the URL
link from there so copy that
go back to Jenkins and add that in the
repository URL so you paste that in and
then for potentials we want to add in
Jenkins credentials and so just make
sure you have those selected correctly
and we've sect add and then we just pull
those from the drop-down and let's not
change any of the other settings and
then from the build we
you're going to be building a java
application so it's a slightly different
set of build commands so we want to type
in Java C book compile and then space
and the file name is simply Java and you
want to put Java and space is simply on
a new line
save that it's again it's a really
simple application but it gives you the
understanding of what you need to do
here and so we saved it and this now go
ahead and see if everything's working
we'll do the build now and see what
happens and here is our first build we
select that we can go to the concert
output for details and what we can
actually see we scroll down is that the
finished add the fish output at the very
end says success which means everything
was built correctly and so that's how
you're able to connect Jenkins with a
git repository and the thing that's
great with working with Jenkins is that
it connects to so many different systems
and really does become the central point
of your DevOps tool set so let's start
looking at the operation side of the dev
ops environment and let's focus in on
docker so before darker the problem you
had as a developer if you're working on
a virtual machine the actual virtual
machine was a your VM was a very complex
piece of software so first of all VMs
have not been around for very long and
we're talking about less than ten years
and the typical way of having a VM is
that it's very heavy for usage on your
computer you essentially are running
everything of the VM plus the the tools
to run the PM on your computer with
docker what you're able to control is
the actual development environment
you're working in you don't have to be
encumbered by all the additional
extraneous processing that a vm
environment has you're really stripped
down to just the bare minimum that you
need to have to run the environment
using a containerized solution known as
calm so doctor is essentially an OS
level virtualization software it is a
maturity of the solutions that were
started with virtual environment and
there are other solutions out there doc
has become de facto
containers solution that you can use for
building out and guaranteed that what
you the developer is building is going
to be the same as what the operations
team will use so doctor itself is highly
scalable and efficient and you can have
many docker environments running on a
single piece of hardware the boot up
time is incredibly short you can reuse
the data volumes very very easily it's
not complicated and the actual
applications are completely isolated
this is like a perfect sandbox
environment so let's take through the
architecture of Dhaka so there are
really two parts to documents the docket
engine there's the docket client the
docket engine is comprised of the docker
CLI which connects with the server
daemon the docker client will then issue
the commands to the docker daemon and
then the docket demon will then interact
with the system to be able to provide
the tasks and tools needed for you to be
able to build out your solution the
actual images that docker uses are
instructions for creating docker
containers and the actual docker
container itself is a lightweight
package it contains all the dependencies
needed to run an application now once
you have created a container that is of
value to your team you want to be able
to store that container so that other
team members can use it and this is
where you would use a docker registry to
be able to host and distribute multiple
docker images so in this video we're
going to go ahead and see how we can get
docker installed and running so we're
gonna go ahead and open up our terminal
window and we want to date whether or
not docker is installed if you haven't
installed this docker you can go ahead
and use the following command and that
is to enter in sudo apt install Danka
and that will go ahead and run the
command to install docker now I already
have dr. installed on my system so I'm
not going to do that right now so I'm
just going to delete that out but what I
am going to do is check to see what
docker images I have installed on my
system and to do that I'm going to type
in sudo docker images and when I run
this will actually show how many images
I have
right now I don't have any images at all
so when we go ahead and install an image
there are two ways you can create an
image for your dog environment one is to
get one from docker hub and the other is
to create your own image and let's go
ahead and get one from docker hub and so
the command line that we want to write
is suno docker pull Redis : and after
the colon we can actually write the name
of the actual file that we're going to
be connecting to from Daka so I'm gonna
go ahead and go to docker hub and I've
already logged in with my user ID in
account so I'm gonna go to docker hub
docker calm is the website address and
I've already logged in with my simple
own account and what you can actually
see is different repositories that I
have already created below but we
clicked the Explorer button and I can
see the the Redis image and these are
all the different commands that I can
actually use all the different
variations that I can create so I can i
I can do 500 I can do a 32-bit version I
can do a 4.0 version or a 3.8 version or
if I select latest that will allow me to
just pull the latest version even if
it's updated so I'm going to go back to
my command line and dude latest and
what's gonna happen now is that we're
gonna pull the files live over the
Internet and create the docker image so
it's gonna take just a few minutes of
course if your internet speed is faster
and this will happen a lot faster
oh yeah we have everything downloaded
which is great and so let's just go and
check and see if the image has been
added to darker so we do sudo docket
images and now you can actually see that
we have the lettuce Rattus Rattus image
and it's given the default image ID and
there's the size of the docker image and
the tag is latest so it's the latest
version of Redis and I'm just checking
to see if there's any other images
running and no there isn't
so let's go ahead and now create a
container and so the command for that is
sudo docker run - d/p 0.00
think it's dot 80 colon 80 space Redis
colon latest and let's run that got an
error message okay now you know that
it's a real demo this is really life so
I'm just going to clear the screen and
let's write that in again and so sudo
docker run - D - P and in 0.0.0.0 colon
8080 radius dog lead colitis and there
we are everything's up and running
awesome so let's just go ahead and check
that we actually have the image running
in docker so sudo docker PS and there
you can see that we actually have the
latest reddest version and it was
created 16 seconds ago we have a new
container ID for it and there's our port
that we've created and let's see if we
can view all the running containers and
sudo docker PS - hey there we are and we
created that container 42 seconds ago
one of these young notice is the name
for the dock is created automatically by
Daka
and here we have stupefied Engelbart's
is the name let's change their names to
something that's more meaningful for the
work that we're doing so that's actually
fairly easy to do and it's gonna be our
final tasks here so we're going to type
sudo darker and the command is renamed
and we want to copy over the old name
and then we put in the old name and they
do a space and then you put in what you
want the new name to be in which case
we're gonna make it simply learn we run
that command that's good now let's
validate that's everything has been
changed so we do sudo
yes - a and just PS and there we are
everything has been renamed and that
gets you started working with dr. now
let's move on to ansible so before
ansible the ability to be able to deploy
software across a network was pretty
hard and you know you couldn't guarantee
that your web servers were all
consistent and that the database
environments were consistent this was
okay if you had a small environment but
once you actually start getting into
more complex environments it became very
difficult to manage ansible is code that
allows you to be able to consistently
and reliably create and stand up the
environments that you need to be able to
store your code for production so
whether or not you require one server
environment or you need a thousand
server environments using tools like
ansible will allow you to be able to
consistently deploy out environments
that all look the same
so essentially ansible is a
configuration management tool and it
allows you to be able to deploy
automatically to a large variety of
environments the actual tool itself is a
push based configuration tool it is an
agentless tool so there is no
communication coming back about the
health of the environment and we
actually have tools that we'll cover
later on the video that cover that as
well does have a consistency of its
product performance so you know that if
you're using ansible that it's going to
work it's just a very consistent product
and it uses SSH for very secure
connections so it doesn't matter whether
or not you have one or a thousand pieces
of hardware you're looking to configure
you can actually be rest assured that
there will be no security infringement
because of the use of SSH and we're
looking to the architecture of ansible
it's a very simple architecture there is
the antral management node that has
playbooks which contains the
instructions that you would have for
your environment and that PlayBook is
then pushed out to all the different
nodes that contain the hardware that you
wish to configure the actual module
collection is the configuration code
itself and the playbooks are the
instructions of that configuration and
then the inventory is the document
the different groups and hardware within
those groups that you can be pushing out
to so we're going to go ahead and
install ansible on to system here and
we're actually running our environment
in a Linux environment right now and so
we have a must return an extended note
but we're just going to go into our
terminal window and we're gonna do
everything on the master node so the
first steps we want to do is actually go
ahead and install ansible and we can do
that by installing sudo yum install
ansible - why and it's goes ahead and
downloads all the files that we need and
starts to run the installation
and let's go ahead and see if it's
installed correctly so we type in VI
- etc - and so all slash hosts and there
we see we actually have a default
ansible hosts already up and running
which is fantastic and we want to grab
this IP address which is ansible servers
and then the IP address with the
password and root access and the IP will
be specific to your local clients so
this is my client system so by typing my
config I'll actually see that the IP
address matches up and then you want to
make sure that your IP address is
correct for your environment and so this
is essentially a node in the ansible
environment and this is the IP address
and the password for that node so can
access affect them correctly so I'm
gonna hit colon at the bottom of the
screen and I guess I was actually into
ansible and we're going to do now is
create a playbook to be able to run a
sample script so we're gonna call it VI
sample dot yml and here we have a sample
playbook we have the name we have the
host we have the right user and we have
the task and in the task you have to see
that we're looking to create a virtual
web page with the content of welcome so
that we actually see that the web page
is loading and all of this is written
with a very basic XML format called
weimar which sounds for yet another
markup language but it's very flexible
and it's very easy to learn so let's see
if we can go ahead and actually run this
playbook so you can actually see it in
action
and so we're going to type in ansible -
playbook and the sample dot yml and this
will run the sample white male script -
- syntax - check every time a pencil
- playbook sampled so I had some issues
there so I'm going to try that again and
there so go in and writes the command
again so ants will - playbook sampled
away Mel - syntax - check and then run
the actual playbook itself and let's see
if it works yes everything's working and
it'll take a moment for everything to
initialize and now what we want to be
able to do is go back to web browser and
see whether or not we were able to
create that default web page with the
word welcome in it because that was the
command that we created in our playbook
and there we are there's the word
welcome exactly as we planned and we can
go back and we can review the playbook
that we created just to validate that so
let's go back into screen here and let's
go in and look at the llamo page and
there we go we see that the word welcome
is there exactly as we expected now step
into our final area which is network
monitoring using a tool called Nagios so
before you had no years sometimes you
didn't know whether or not your network
was working in fact the worst case
scenario was when your customers caught
up is it hey your website's not working
you know the challenges you had is that
you didn't know how the usage of the
server was being managed you didn't know
whether you up to 80% usage utilization
on that server of you were at 50% it was
difficult to get that information easily
with Nagios you're able to set up email
notifications and other notifications
that allow you to stay ahead of issues
that you would have within your
environment so with this example if
you're looking for memory utilization
you can receive a notification telling
you that your memory is almost full on a
particular server and that you should be
setting up a new server in this instance
use Hansel to set up another server so
again it's an as with the other tools
that we
covering Nagios is an open-source tool
and it's specifically for monitoring
systems servers and networks within your
infrastructure very easy to use it has
comprehensive monitoring tools that you
could set control it is highly available
and it is designed specifically a
problem remediation you want to set it
up so there is the eyes and ears of your
network without you having to constantly
monitor your network so the way that
Negus works is that it's just constantly
checking out your environment so the
know your server is constantly checking
the status of your systems and then is
able to create visualization tools all
of that data so you can actually then
make quick responses or you can even
send out alerts such as an email or push
notification alert in this video we're
going to take you through the steps that
you need to follow if you want to set up
Nagios and the dashboard now gives
provides to be a help to help monitor
your network so the first thing you want
to do is go to NASSCOM and you can
either download the application or you
can actually do what we're gonna do here
is actually just log into the actual
application running on the nine years
website so for that you want to go to
now use na demos doc Magoo's comm and
you can use the administration or normal
user access IDs that Nagios provides and
we've gone ahead and we've actually pre
filled in our ID with no years admin and
now you must admin for the username and
password of course so that brings us
into the Nagios dashboard and what
you're gonna notice that there are three
distinct areas that you should want to
focus on you have the fixed sources
which is all your actual fiscal hardware
that you're monitoring you have alert
summary and abnormal behavior so let's
go check out the fixed sources so we
have to default fixed sources here and
why don't you can go one in Tulsa and
and you can go ahead and set up
additional sources but what you'll see
is that this surprise a quick dashboard
of the activity in the last 30 minutes
the amount of usage on the disk you can
go ahead and do the behavior tab and you
can modify how you're monitoring and
updating the actual sauce
so and then the data from these reports
will be from these sources well actually
then user reports queries and alerts
that you'll use so we'll go back to the
board and here is though to fix sources
so this look at lo summary when you
expand it out and the other summary
provides just a overview of the alerts
that are being managed the others that
you see here are the default alerts that
have been created as part of the test
environment it's very easy to create
alerts and in this instance you can see
that the Chicago sauce is being used to
merge the alert what you can do is when
you're actually setting up your own
sources you'll see that the alert will
then point specifically to the source
that it's pulling the data from so in
the PowerPoint in the presentation that
we just went through you actually see
how Nagios and aji is the center of
collecting all the information but it's
actually pulling information from the
different networks and environments you
have and then it stores that data
locally to be able to create the
visualizations and the alerts and we
have here just a quick overview of an
alert here inside of the summary which
actually shows green which shows that
the alert is actually good now there are
three different types of colors there's
green yellow and gray but you can see we
have no critical alerts right now and
you'll see the same thing happening and
abnormal behavior as well where actually
goes ahead and shows you the different
colors that are available the thing
that's great is but as soon as a warning
status is created then allows you to
trigger an email notification that gets
sent out to you and has information in
the email which you can then action so
the alerts are very important in the
alert again are pulling information from
the fixed sources so they have no
behavior is just gonna zero in and show
any specific I've known behavior that
would be happening with your fixed
sources and so in this instance it's
around bandwidth and everything is green
so everything's looking good so we're
going to the source tab but we're gonna
look at the bandwidth graph and this is
a more detailed visualization of the
bandwidth that have playing through the
Chicago fixed source again you can
create your own fix sources and you'll
be able to see the actual usage such as
the bandwidth graph for that fixed
source on this screen and the
the screen we have just kind of the the
most popular information that most
network engineers are looking to assess
on how a network is being used so you
hit a Mickey suck reports and we can
actually come in and we can either
create our own custom report or you can
use one of the many saved reports are
already there if your new scenarios
use the save reports because you'll be
able to get in and get the great
visualization tools that Nagios provides
very quickly and be able to then action
the information visually from what
you're looking at these reports are
absolutely fantastic and it was a really
good to send to other team members that
would have an interest in understanding
the network usage and the different
areas that you're imagining now if you
want to get really specific on the type
of data that you want in the report you
can actually go in and create a query
and the query can be customized to
really however you want it to it to work
the points of view are very specific
insights into different data points that
interact and they're very easy to create
and a lot of them have been created as
you can see on the screen already and as
you can see on the left hand side there
is an edit button that allows you to
edit and modify those points of view
very quickly now we're going to go ahead
and create one right now and we're just
going to put one in and put the limiter
for IP address we're gonna change the
dead lifetime united to alice days a
week so we did 24 hours is fine so we'll
just go ahead and we'll see what we have
on the screen and as you can see there
are just a lot already created select
one will edit the FTP and we'll see what
the only time for that is and it all
looks good to a query will show all the
saved queries you've created but you can
actually go in and modify a query very
easy you can go in and create a query
and really essentially ask it to pull
any kind of information that you would
be looking at analyzing that has been
captured by now yes and there's a
dictionary you can use that no use has
on their website that allows you to get
better access in on sunny
the querying constructs you can put
together the alerts in my opinion are
the most important part because these
are the attractions are interact with
the data sources and
will trigger alerts that get sent to you
so go back to the presentation again you
can see that we're analyzing a lot of
data but it's the data that gets sent
here as an alert that allows you to
immediately understand why you need to
be able to go in and check out your
network and this is why you're really
using negatives because you need to have
those alerts and so what we're going to
do here is we're going through the steps
you used to create an alert and we're
just gonna do a light here that is gonna
be on analyzing bytes of traffic and the
final step is to actually go ahead and
save the alert and really put in what
the alert notification model method is
going to be and the default is to use an
email which is great but you can use an
Aggie ice alert or as you know SMP a
simple Network protocol or just use it
and a command email is definitely the
easiest one to use and so getting
started I would recommend you use email
so we're gonna go ahead and we're gonna
create one and you want on workflow and
we're going to set up the way which we
gonna manage this so yeah thresholds
gonna be 34 bytes or with a critical
threshold of 50 bytes which is very
small
I expect an alert to be triggered
because of this and we're just going to
use the default emails to send out and
you'll see by default that the new alert
is now in painting and and the reason
why we have impending is that it's just
there to be reviewed by the system to
make sure it meets all the standards I
don't think there'll be a problem and
I'm just looking at some of the other
different commands we have here so we go
back and we can get alerts from other
negatives networks which connects to
different networks right from this
configuration screen and the same thing
with the SMP receiver we can use simple
network management protocol to connect
to other receivers and the command tab
allows us to create scripts that can be
triggered from alerts that get created
so you may want to have something that
triggers a rebuild of a network
environment which would allow you to
authenticate through other systems now
of course there are other things you can
set up in the negev dashboard so you
know things like information work
profile you know defaults here
such as language and your username you
have the same thing for a system
administrator where you can get you go
in and set defaults for the sysadmin
there's LDAP AD integration for simple
and for sam'l authentication go back to
the main dashboard if we scroll down
you'll actually see that till we have an
alert has been approved that's the alert
that creating forum and it's now saying
critical and because more than 50 bytes
of information have been sent over our
test Network and the fix source of
Chicago surprise - 50 bytes is very easy
to do so it's good to see that the
system is working correctly and this is
how our new years of brandman works and
from here the next step is for you to be
able to set up and configure Negi OHS -
wrong with your infrastructure that's it
we covered everything that you need to
start up your DevOps environment and we
encourage you to be able to go through
and play with the different tools if you
have any questions please post them in
the comments below we always respond to
questions that you have there we have a
team of people from looking at those
questions today and if you like this
video we have a significant number of
other videos and all you have to do is
either go throughout the yo cat blog or
hit this sub subscribe and like button
and you'll be notified when new videos
drop have a great day in DevOps land
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here